ми також вважаємо, що
слід запобігти подальшій ескалації напруженості
Розробник Сполучені Штати
підтримують народ України, який
протягом майже трьох років страждав
від російської окупації та військового
втручання, поки Росія та
сепаратисти, яких вона підтримує, не почнуть
поважати суверенітет і територіальну
цілісність України в цій кризі  продовжуватиметься,
східна Україна, звичайно, не
єдина частина країни, яка страждає
через агресивні дії Росії,
Сполучені Штати продовжують
засуджувати та закликати до негайного
припинення російської окупації Криму Крим
є частиною України Наші санкції щодо Криму
будуть  залишатися на місці, доки
Росія не поверне контроль над
півостровом Україні диригент Авіла багато чого
ми хочемо покращити наші
відносини з Росією, однак жахлива
ситуація на сході України
вимагає чіткого та рішучого засудження
дій Росії там для сьогоднішнього
обговорення має на меті  сприяти
поселенню  конфлікту